Richard zane
would love to hear about anxiety.
Well that's,
that's a rough thing to have egg or a phobia.
So agoraphobic get increasingly isolated and afraid of things outside of their
domain and familiarity.
And often what happens with Agora phobia is that people who develop it or afraid
of two things,
they're afraid that something is going to go dreadfully wrong with their health,
especially with regards to their heart.
So they start to become afraid that maybe they'll have a heart attack and that
they'll die in public,
far from a hospital and that they'll make a fool of themselves while they're
doing it or well they,
well they think they're dying.
So it's a combination of two fears and one is fear of mortality and the other is
fear of social judgement.
And you might think about those as the two main categories of fear that
possessed people because one is associated,
well obviously with mortality and death and the other is associated with
exclusion from the group,
which of course can lead to mortality and death.
And so the agoraphobic is the worst of both worlds.
It's often a disease of middle aged women.
But not always.
And there are often people who've been somewhat dependent in their previous
lives and then undergo some traumatic event,
like a divorce or the death of someone close.
And,
and at the same time,
our perhaps experiencing heart palpitations that are associated with menopause
that brings ideas of mortality to mind and that can trigger a panic attack,
which is very,
um,
what would you call it?
Unpleasant experience to say the least.
Um,
and then that fear of panic attack starts making people avoid and that's when
Agra phobia develops out of anxiety disorders with panic attack.
So you go out and maybe you go to a mall and maybe you're in a crowd and maybe
you start thinking about,
well,
your heartbeat and about the fact that someone close to you is died.
And maybe then you become aware of your heartbeat and you start to panic because
you feel that maybe it's the beat is irregular or or that or that you can't
detect it as well as you usually can.
And then that makes your heart accelerate because it makes you afraid.
And then you get more more,
what would you call sensitive to that and that makes your heart rate beat even
faster.
And then you panic.
You want to get to the hospital to get checked out to make sure that you're all
right and then you make your fatal mistake,
which is that you avoid going back to the mall and then you go to a grocery
store in the same thing happens and then you start to avoid going to the grocery
store.
Then you start avoid avoiding the subway or taxis or crowds or anywhere you
might get trapped and wouldn't be able to get to the hospital.
Soon you end up avoiding everything and that's when your life really starts to
become a living hell.
So the basic way to treat egg or a phobia,
there's two ways.
One is to develop some control of breathing,
to do progressive relaxation.
The way you do that is that you start with your,
you start by concentrating on your toes and your feet and your ankles,
and then your shins and your knees.
You move all the way up your body and let the tension flow out of your muscles
and regulate your breathing calmly and carefully so that you can learn to relax.
And then you go out,
you go out voluntarily and start to confront the things you're afraid of.
So for example,
if you're afraid of the mall,
maybe you go to the parking lot and you look at the mall and then you walk close
to the door and you look inside,
you know,
and then you go home because that's enough for one day.
But you do progressive exposure.
And that's the base.
One of the basic rules of psychotherapy is that if you're afraid of something,
you progressively and voluntarily expose yourself to it.
And that generally it's the voluntary exposure that's curative,
right?
Accidental exposure can make you worse,
but voluntary exposure can be curative.
And that's sort of associated with the myth of the hero and the Dragon.
You know,
the hero is the person who goes out voluntarily to confront the dragon and
overcome it and get the treasurer.
And so if you voluntarily expose yourself to things you're afraid of,
like no more than you can tolerate,
then you'll find that you get braver and you learn that you can tolerate the
fear and that can chase the or phobia back.
And it's very important to do it on a regular basis.
And if you have agoraphobic,
a full fledged agoraphobic and you should probably consult professional help
because it's a very tricky condition and it can be very,
can really impair you badly.
So that's what I would recommend.
Hi Jp.
I'm wondering how the computer program that rates university courses as
worthwhile or not is coming along well,
it isn't rating them as worthwhile.
It's rating them as postmodern,
Neil Marxist or not and it's actually fully developed.
I was going to launch it and I didn't,
I didn't design it.
Uh,
somebody volunteered to design it and presented it to me and it seems to work
very well.
Um,
I was going to launch it at the end of August so that this year's university
students could benefit from it.
But there was the Charlottesville event and then I got busy and I also wasn't
feeling great and so I just didn't hit the window of time properly.
But I hope to be able to launch it for the January incoming class to do a video
about what's wrong with the university system,
that many things that are wrong with the university system and to launch the
website at the same time.
Also had people suggest to me that maybe it wasn't a good idea that it would
increase polarization,
but I've thought about that for about a month and a half.
And I think that the benefit to the consumer,
so that would be the informed student outweighs any danger of polarization.
And besides that,
something has to be done because the situation in the universities is really
ridiculous.
So,
all right,
so let's see what else we've got here in the chat room.
That's quite a mouthful.
Says I'm studying to be a teacher,
but I'm also an introvert.
Could this be a big problem?
Can I still be a successful teacher?
Actually what seems to predict success of teaching best is intelligence and
conscientiousness.
That's the data so far.
So if you're conscientious,
then you'll probably be fine.
I mean extra introverts have a harder time speaking in front of groups,
but you can learn to do that.
You know,
an introvert can become a very successful public speaker.
May Not enjoy it the same way that an extrovert might,
but that doesn't mean that you can't learn the skills.
And when I would recommend for an introvert is the same thing that I do when I'm
lecturing is I never talked to the whole group.
You know,
it doesn't matter how big the crowd is,
I'm always picking out individuals in the group and talking specifically to
them.
So I'll make a point to an individual and I watched their face and see if
they're nodding and understanding.
Right?
Because that way you make contact with the entire audience and then you know,
all talk to someone for about 15 seconds or so.
I don't want to put them on the spot too much.
And then I shift my attention to someone else and I sort of pinpoint around the
room and that keeps everybody in the room focused on what I'm saying,
because each person reflects the entire crowd back to you.
And so I would say if you're an introvert or if you want to speak in public in
general,
forget about the damn crowd.
It doesn't exist.
Speak to people one on one at a time.
And an introvert can do that just fine.
So you know,
that's where your strength would be.
And I would say you're,
you're much more likely to be unsuccessful as a teacher if you don't work hard
at it.
And if you're not interested in it.
So if you're an introvert,
I wouldn't worry about that.
Um,
I don't think that that'll be the biggest problem that you'll face.
So.